let's give this one a go let's give this
one a try shall we now this time because
it was my bent eye I went to them
graphing method first and then I went to
the cordials method second just
different names for the same thing just
for the sake of it let's go to this
method first and see if we can answer it
this way okay so you've got tan you've
got a given domain 10 is negative so
which quadrants am i interested in 2 & 4
2 & 4 okay so those are the ones I'm
gonna go to all right now in my other
color you don't have to worry about the
sign when you're working is part out
what's the base angle the related angle
for tan x equals minus 1 hmm so a way
you can think about it an easy way to
get the related angle and sometimes you
have to do this because it's not in
exactly if you just look at this thing
don't worry about the sign for a second
and you think out what's the first angle
that salsa and it's 45 degrees okay your
calculator will tell you that it could
do tan inverse of minus 1 then you pop
the sign back on and that tells you
which quadrants your 45 degrees will be
in let's draw it 45 degrees we'll go
that way so your first angle is what's
the size hundred thirty five right
because it's 45 degrees that way okay so
he's solution number one and solution
number two you told me quadrant four
right so I've got to go all the way
around this way so I get 45 here right
so what's that size 315 very good okay
you go that's it nothing too dramatic
okay a third example this time I'm gonna
switch it up a little bit let's go
oops
so I've changed the domain here and I'm
pointing out you you won't always get it
pointed out to you you have to look for
yourself okay now I will say like we
went straight to the quadrants here I'll
just quickly draw what's happening for
this second one right this was 10
what does tan looked like from naught to
360 you're gonna get up here asymptotes
down asymptotes and you've got your two
copies of 10 because 10 is periodic
every 180 degrees right where are two
solutions minus one so again here isn't
it so there's your 135 and there's your
315 all happy times ok now I've been
kind of agnostic with these ones as to
which approach you use it roughly
equivalent ok but here here I think if
start is where the graphical method
really starts to take over ok
because I couldn't look at this in terms
of quadrants right except if I think
about this domain here we usually think
of this as not to 90 92 180 180 270 and
270 to 360 and that's fairly natural and
you should think about it that way but
that way won't work when you're looking
at this domain will it right instead
you've got to think ok this is gonna be
0 to 90 life before this is 90 to 180
like before but this is not one agent
270 cuz 180 270 is not in your domain
okay
and neither is to something for 360
instead
how'd you suggest I write this
this is going to be negative 92 zero and
this is negative 182 negative nine okay
now you don't need me to tell you this
is going to start getting confusing very
fast okay um it'll still work you can
still get the same solutions it behaves
in exactly the same way but I find when
I teach students this way they get this
sign so confused it's just not worth it
okay so I'm gonna ditch the quadrants
approach for this and I'm going to draw
a graph the graph of sine X from minus
180 to 180 is just as easy to draw as
the graph from 0 to 360 there you go can
you see that's from minus 180 180 we're
familiar with this shape it's just we're
looking a different part okay and this
makes it even easier to see where is
minus 1 on this graph
sorry where's my stuff on this graph I
should say there's minus 1 right so
minus 1/2 would be there ok so now I can
slice through and I can straightaway see
where my solutions will be and one two
and they're both negative ok in fact
because I've chosen such an easy exact
value you can probably tell me what the
answers are right now right I gotta go
minus 30 that way or I'm gonna have to
go all the way over here which is minus
150 right done no concern about which
quadrants you're in you just look at the
graph and you see where it intersects